in realtà o semplicemente qualcosa da
ricordarvi oggi qualcosa di molto
semplice nella sua complessità
per farlo ho deciso di condividere con
voi una storia una storia breve è però
nel punto mettere insieme questa storia
mi sono reso conto che non avrei trovato
le tutte le giuste argomentazioni
diciamo in un passato recente
quindi mi sono reso conto che in realtà
forse aveva più senso partire da un
passato più remoto addirittura proprio
dalle origini
qual è il primo senso che l'essere umano
attiva e l'udito è l'ascolto la prima
azione che cominciamo a compiere è
quella di ascoltare quasi come se fosse
in ci sono nel nostro dna questa
priorità ad ascoltare noi stessi e gli
altri e quindi il nostro cervello
comincia a ricevere dell'input
dall'esterno dei suoni dei suoni alcuni
strutturati come le parole tramite ad
esempio la voce di nostra madre
e infatti la storia che vi sto per
raccontare è una storia che si basa
sull'ascolto e sul linguaggio quante
sono le lingue in cui l'uomo si esprime
con quante lingue l'uomo comunica nel
mondo ve lo siete chiesti oggi giorno in
2015 quante lingue parliamo al mondo
questo il numero delle lingue parlate al
mondo tra lingue dialetti
secondo una statistica internazionale
7.106 lingue ma ci comprendiamo davvero
tutti vuole dire l'uomo davvero si
comprende con tutte queste lingue così
diverse tra loro
chiaro abbiamo delle lingue che sono
maggiormente diffuse spagnolo l'arabo il
cinese
l'inglese che ovviamente utilizziamo
come lingua globale ma c'è stato un
tempo in cui l'uomo parlava meno lingue
o addirittura parlavano una lingua sola
mito e storia ci raccontano di simili in
realtà c'è stato un tempo migliaia
migliaia di anni fa mito e storia in cui
l'uomo probabilmente parlava una lingua
sola una lingua universale
pensate che bello forse forse no
che tutti gli uomini del mondo tutti gli
uomini che si incontra sono che si
incontravano all'epoca potevano
comunicare con la stessa lingua
poi però sempre mite storia si
raccontano avere l'uomo di questa sua
capacità di questa sua conoscenza del
suo sapere ne ha fatto un ambizione
forse troppo grande e quindi nel
costruire la famosa torre di babele
quindi nell'ambito ad arrivare oltre i
suoi limiti
beh testato è stato punito e quindi la
divinità ha mandato tra gli uomini tante
lingue ha creato caos attraverso la
diversità delle lingue ma è rimasta una
lingua che l'uomo a disposizione per
comprendersi forse sì una lingua
universale ancora sempre e della musica
la musica è quel linguaggio che
attraverso i suoni permettere di
esprimere permette di esprimere qualcosa
di diverso delle parole o le volte
supporta anche le parole nell'esprimere
meglio è un concetto e quindi la musica
è quel linguaggio fatto di suoni
organizzati e strutturati che aiutano
l'uomo a esprimersi a esprimere i suoi
sentimenti le sue emozioni le sue idee e
le sue convinzioni la sua cultura
quando è nata la musica
questo è il primo strumento musicale a
meno così gli scienziati ricercatori ci
dicono che è stato rinvenuto in slovenia
è un piccolo pezzo di osso di 43 mila
anni fa
sembrerebbe che questo piccolo pezzo di
osso fosse il primo flauto della storia
l'uomo di neanderthal se ne serviva per
creare dei suoni 43 mila anni fa
questo sempre secondo i ricercatori può
essere considerato il primo spartito
musicale è stato rinvenuto in siria ed
eder risale all'epoca del 1.400 avanti
cristo
quindi già capiamo la necessità che
l'uomo aveva di fissare questi suoni
questa sua capacità di accompagnare il
linguaggio parlato con un linguaggio
fatto di suoni interessante vedere come
sia il primo strumento musicale che il
primo spartito musicale in qualche modo
fossero rinvenuti in europa nel
mediterraneo
ovviamente poi la storia della musica è
stata accompagnata ha sempre
accompagnato la storia dell'evoluzione
dell'uomo in italia proprio monaco guido
d'arezzo ha stabilito il sistema di
notazione musicale che tutti poi oggi
noi conosciamo ma ovviamente la musica
avuto le sue evoluzioni e quindi tanti
tanti compositori uomini si sono
espressi tramite la musica
nell'arco della storia addirittura
quella musica ha una capacità di
rappresentare un identità di una nazione
di un popolo di una cultura e quindi i
nostri nazionali
addirittura nel 72 la commissione
europea all'unione europea ha stabilito
che ci fosse bisogno di un inno europeo
e quindi è stato scelto l'inno alla
gioia della nona di beethoven
ovviamente tutte queste diverse culture
musicali del mondo sono strettamente
intrecciate tra loro
curioso vedere come la musica moderna in
qualche modo sia nata dalla tradizione
africana sia nata da il movimento che
questa è cultura
questa identità musicale africana ha
portato poi nel mondo curioso vedere che
è venuto attraverso un fenomeno
piuttosto triste attraverso ad esempio
la schiavitù e quindi questi uomini e
donne che viaggiavano ma in testé navi
verso l'america e si esprimevano
esprimere il proprio dolore attraverso
la musica che poi ha fatto nascere il
jazz e il blues il rock e tutti gli
altri generi che conosciamo quindi da
questa piccola tavoletta 1400
l'anticristo siamo in qualche modo
arrivati anche a questo che ci sono i
due dischi d'oro che nel 1977 la massa
ha inviato nello spazio con il programma
voyager e su questi dischi è inciso il
nostro sapere la nasa ha detto beh
incidiamo su questi dischi che
viaggeranno nello spazio per i prossimi
40 mila anni quello che è un po la summa
del nostro sapere e hanno deciso anche
di inserire il 90 minuti di musica e
nello spazio oggi per i prossimi 40 mila
anni
viaggerà alla quinta sinfonia di
beethoven
johnny b.good di chuck berry è così
pensate tra 40mila anni probabilmente
questi dischi saranno ascoltati da
qualche nostro fratello in qualche
pianeta molto lontano che metterà li
ascolterà johnny b.good ma la musica è
ovviamente si fa e qual è la carriera
capacità la forza della musica quella di
aggregare e ovviamente una stessa
sinfonica è la massima espressione di
questa capacità di aggregazione nella
diversità tanti strumenti diversi
si crea un armonia così un coro ma
ovviamente non solo negli ensemble e nei
gruppi che conosciamo noi da questa
parte del mondo vale anche per
ovviamente l'asia il giappone e tutte le
varie forme ovviamente musicali non solo
quella classica quattro ragazzi assieme
sono riusciti a comunicare a tutto il
mondo la musica quindi ha una capacità
sociale estremamente forte e ci sono
molti esempi nella storia recente di
progetti che hanno sfruttato questa
capacità della musica di unire di
formare di educare e quindi ad esempio
in venezuela con il sistema di a breve
un sistema di educazione che ha salvato
centinaia di migliaia di ragazzi dalle
strade dalla povertà semplicemente
mettendoli in mano uno strumento
musicale facendogli capire che
formandosi studiando apprendendo la
capacità di suonare uno strumento
avrebbero potuto avere un futuro diverso
ma la musica la capacità anche di unire
ragazzi giovani adulti di culture
diverse cose che magari invece non
riesce a fare la diplomazia o la
politica né stata una dimostrazione
il progetto di al direttore barenboim
che con la sua orchestra messo insieme
giovani palestinesi italiani e hard ma
ovviamente la musica unisce in tutte le
parti del mondo in africa in paraguay ad
esempio siamo bellissimo progetto in cui
le giovani utilizzando del materiale di
scarto di riciclo hanno fatto degli
strumenti musicali in egitto dei
semplici ragazzi c'è che hanno
costituito un orchestra che oggi gira il
mondo
ma la musica ovviamente anche una
grandissima colonna sonora della storia
dell'uomo
la musica è presente molto spesso quando
accade qualcosa di straordinario di
importante quasi a testimoniare
l'esigenza di raccontarla di spiegarlo
non solo con le parole
e quindi ad esempio la caduta del muro
di berlino è stata in qualche modo
accompagnata raccontata dal violoncello
di una rete di grandi musicisti del
novecento lo straw pollici ma anche
appunto da un musicista che con dal suo
letto in qualche modo comunicava al
mondo un messaggio di pace accompagnata
ovviamente al messaggio di pace delle
sue canzoni e la musica unisce pensiamo
a tutti i grandi concerti in cui persone
con idee diverse con esperienze diverse
sono lì ad ascoltare e ovviamente
proprio per questa capacità della musica
di comunicare di creare dialogo la
musica è presente anche laddove dialogo
non c'è dove non c'è armonia e quindi
dove se guerra e quando se guerra non
può esserci musica ma la musica in
qualche modo può fare qualcosa per
evitare la guerra quindi la disarmonia
quindi la violenza quindi l'ignoranza
ecco noi nel centro del mediterraneo a
malta
abbiamo provato a fare un piccolo
esperimento per un mese un gruppo di
giovani maltesi ed un gruppo di giovani
ragazzi africani rifugiati a malta sono
stati insieme gli abbiamo dato delle
percussioni e questi ragazzi hanno
cominciato a suonare veramente senza
foga guida da soli ci insegnava al 1 ti
insegnava all'altro hanno cominciato a
suonare semplice molto semplice
sembrerebbe però questi giovani in
realtà non comunicavano tra loro nella
loro vita quotidiana
beh alla fine dopo un mese si è creato
un grandissimo entusiasmo e questi
ragazzi sono riusciti
a diventare un gruppo a diventare un
ensemble che poteva comunicare verso
l'esterno che aveva qualcosa da dire
verso l'esterno e quindi abbiamo
organizzato un concerto pubblico e in
questo concerto alla fine è stato
interessante vedere come i ruoli erano
completamente stravolti il giovane
ragazzo africano che era venuto lì per
imparare beh era diventato il nostro
direttore d'orchestra e questo ragazzo
durante il concerto ha detto non ci può
essere musica suonando solo i tasti neri
di un pianoforte
sì magari qualche compositore avrebbe
qualcosa da ridire si può fare anche ma
il suo concetto deve dire per fare buona
musica e quindi per avere l'armonia
bisogna suonare tasti nieri e tasti
bianchi rende molto aiuto extra and
young a fotografici di hunger figisc
come nikkei molti evidentemente la
musica non può fermare un proiettile o
non può ricostruire un palazzo crollato
o non può salvare delle vite
non può farlo direttamente lo può fare
indirettamente la musica l'arte la
cultura e quindi l'educazione la
formazione possono fermare un proiettile
possono ricostruire un palazzo possono
evitare che poi proietti le parti
possono evitare che quel palazzo crolli
ecco questo è quello che volevo
ricordarvi oggi la capacità della musica
di comunicare verso tutti perché quando
la musica parla tutti comprendono e io
sono sicuro che se adesso noi facciamo
un attimo di silenzio e anch'io
fermo il mio racconto possiamo fare
esperienza di questo tutti assieme ad
esso qui perché la musica è nell'aria e
così come 43 mila anni fa
l'uomo di neanderthal lo aveva capito e
aveva cercato qualcosa per intercettare
questi suoni questa musica
beh sono sicuro che lo possiamo fare
anche noi oggi qui perché come dicevo
prima
dove c'è armonia dove c'è rispetto
dove c'è ascolto c'è musica e allora mi
fermo un attimo
ascoltiamo un attimo